let's continue hearing from folks in the
audience I want to go next to royland
from Grand Rapids royland welcome what
is on your mind today
hey David nice talking to you again uh
last time I talked about model monetary
Theory but this time I'll keep it with
voting since that's everybody's mind
beautiful
uh first of all thanks for pronouncing
my name correctly it's really rare that
that happens I don't know how else how
else could it be pronounced it seems so
obvious I've gotten Roland raylen I
don't even know
if yeah people don't look like they can
pronounce the first time I just say Roy
just say Roy beautiful okay fine well
I'm glad to have you here
yeah so quick question
um so I'm trying to get people to vote
but obviously the ballots are all over
the place of confusing with candidates
do you have like any references or
websites that you refer to for just uh
progressively endorsed candidates or
places that are like you know
kind of some kind of list of candidates
that you that people would endorse for a
progressive caucus or anything I
probably should have asked this during
the primaries and not the midterms but
no I don't have any I thought you were
going to ask a place where you can
figure out exactly where you vote based
on your address and can you vote early
and can you vote absentee and all of
these different things I'm not aware of
any central place for like an
endorsement type thing because the
endorsements are made
organizations make it there's no
official Progressive endorsements
there's different organizations which
claim to be the Clearinghouse for who
should be who should be voted for but no
I I don't know that such a central thing
really exists
that's so unfortunate because I have
people that are like ready to vote but
when they get to the things like uh like
I'm in Michigan and uh when you get past
the parts that say like what the
Democrats are they don't really know who
to vote for
um so yeah so listen what I would
recommend is if you just search on
Google
for Michigan ballot 2022 the first
result is a Michigan Secretary of State
website where you put in exactly where
you vote you put in your County uh you
put in the jurisdiction so it seems some
counties like for example you know Bay
County you put in exactly where you are
you even put in your Precinct and then
it will show you your exact ballot your
exact ballot with everything that's on
it as a starting point familiarize
yourself with what you will be voting
for and then like for example you know
in Michigan whatever wherever I'm
looking here there's a proposal to make
some changes to how elections are
financed you can look at that in advance
and and research what it is you believe
about that so these aren't secrets you
know you don't have to wait until
election day and then get all confused
about the things you're voting on just
Google it Google where you live and you
can find the exact ballot you will have
absolutely yeah I was kind of more
asking for like the lazy person you know
because I I'm aware of all this but I
just would love to lend send a reference
to people that are I mean sadly the lazy
thing is to just you vote all for
Democrats or all Republicans in the
races that are partisan which aren't all
of them necessarily there's like
nonpartisan male races but there are
shortcuts of people are looking for them
I don't know that I recommend them
like I said this probably should have
been a question for during the primaries
and not this far into the election but I
haven't had a chance to call since then
but also one more thing I have had a
chance to call since you since you had
your uh child congratulations on that
thank you um I do remember an episode
where you kind of like had to address a
brief that some of the viewers have been
giving you about
um ticking time off to spend time with
your children yeah your child and I
think that's just that's so
disappointing as a viewer as a listener
that you had to make those comments
because you're supposed to be like you
know a beacon for Progressive thoughts
and you know paid fraternity leave
paternity leave is General something we
should all aspire to be so the fact that
you get the ability to do that is you
know I I I a lot of people probably envy
that and I think that on your next child
if you were to take a whole month off
there there's plenty of us that would be
totally understanding and happy for you
nonetheless well I very much appreciate
that royland thank you for making that
declaration I like it
yes all right well you have a good rest
your day man okay you too there's
royland with uh very important questions
from Grand Rapids Michigan yes
understand the ballot that you will be
presented with just Google it you can
find it easily